why do I have to be straddling Bob and
riding them down the corridor what can I
be straddling my nurse hello everybody
my name is markiplier and I'm currently
in a crisis because apparently oh that
came out of there pretty easily
apparently there's another mode called
know my different brew Liberator I know
I'll need that oh come on they're down
there thank you I know that I'm gonna
need that very soon as hearts about to
stop
I need whoa oh okay okay
I hope these get new every time with the
button push the button push the button
and then go for it go for it baby oh my
god this is crisis to the extreme oh
stop hitting his lung it is gosh turn
ribbed at the sternum in there Oh God
you think eventually we'd reached our
destination okay use me
I get the bone bone bone bone bone bone
bone bone I have no way of stopping the
bleeding I don't think anyway no at the
bone there we go put that out of there
yeah please that's still hanging on
there oh no those die on me now Bob
oh we've come too far we've come too far
okay I need Oh Oh God clear I said clear
oh I got him okay I thought it was death
the sweet embrace of death was closing
in on me
me and Bobby knew stop that stop that
how hard is it to stop that okay so you
come here conveniently placed ham arm is
this what's holding it in there we go
god get out of there
yeah yeah get out of it long long no
time to mess around
we're now lung-lung we're bleeding out I
need a knife scalpel thingy nurse what
do you call those things whoo thank you
nurse
oh I don't want to call Tricia that's
what they need no that no that no no
give me give me
what is this cup holder it's not what I
need
how's this gonna cut an esophagus oh god
get back I know what a highlighter this
is a goddamn nightmare
oh well Bob the bailiff there's nothing
I can do because apparently you're just
gonna die with it okay god this is like
the most panic inducing thing I've ever
done in my life you drill perfect it
pour here so you're gonna be by
precision instrumented by God's to lean
down camera you [ __ ] oh god get out of
there okay oh okay all right okay crisis
barely averted
Oh ho-ho I'm gonna cut your heart out Oh
stop scaring me with the death he's not
dying yet I'm not done drilling yet
there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
what do I need what do I need you know
no you there cut cut cut
good good good I'll get these organs out
of there later just like I'll get the
gorgonzola out of me later
oh no no no no lean down ah camera
camera you [ __ ] oh where did you go I
still have a hold of it apparently
trying to maybe maybe not
okay get out of it you did it you did it
you know what was that on the ground
it's not a head
what was that the lung okay you are you
no no no you know you you know oh come
on I missed it
oh you need to calm down I need to calm
down give me a spoon oh good a scalpel
is that do I actually have that oh god
camera you [ __ ] camera
okay got it
OOP stop okay where's my heart where my
heart go word bar dr need a heart beat
heart heart heart there's no hard on
their feet heart Bob remember I need a
hard Bob I need a heart I'll take that
stop the bleeding for now good I hear
won't need you ever again
where's my heart Oh hard Oh God there it
is
give me give me open you come here and
victory victory victory toes so I got a
boob the heart oh why aren't you working
you upside down do I need to flip you
around get you in there why is this not
working what is this not working what's
going on what do I need to do I don't
know what I need to do I don't know
would one for me I thought I did it
clear with a dead heart in it who gave
me a bad heart
is it Chloe didn't you didn't oh there's
a piece of bone in there that what's
wrong what's wrong
hopefully tell me I was wrong all right
I was actually sweating I was literally
sweating from this broad cos is very hot
in this room but besides the point I was
sweating and I'm also not gonna cheat
Giada just one I'm gonna give it to four
we're gonna do both the heart and the
kidney all in one so that we could get
this done and then we'll deal with the
eyeballs and teeth another
I know the teeth is gonna be a whole
separate episode because it's giant
prick today teeth prick okay come on
there we go give me something useful
that is that is not exactly what I had
in mind when I said useful but okay here
we go
okay one cut to cut to cut you cut cut
got it last cut last incision as they
would call it doctor you're so smart
with the medical words thank you nurse I
know but still shut up cuz I'm very
strain you ated oh god okay I hit the
who I hit the common gases we don't have
to worry about a thing on this one
it's gonna blow it's Barry let's see if
I can get back there perfectly that's
the clear some stuff out of here without
letting go of my cutting device okay
turn off the gas there we go
yeah alright Oh heart rate go up then I
cut it I think it's cut they could get
that out of there my stuff where's my
stuff where's my kidneys gonna throw one
of these in there give me my bottle of
soda why is this liver still here put
the liver back in there liver was still
probably pretty good so he probably was
that big in there ah where's Micah days
oh this is a dab of glue stick glue
stick oh I lost my glue no it's over
here we'll stick will stick syrup kid no
ain't no kidneys these kidneys by
beneath your knees I know your heart
rate will high kidney kidney baby give
it to me give me all your kidneys cuz
you're a frickin [ __ ] and he's
bleeding to death yeah Rick here we go
put this over there but I can hold on
this is worse than the ambulance
please is hard backup you need Kenny
doctor the kidneys are on the way
shut up nurse get him to me now I need
him now we didn't know as they would say
oh there we go finally let see if I can
get both kidneys in here before it goes
away
give me that another one give me you
liver get out of the way all was that
dead kidney doing in there the bat-beam
get it out of there whoo first try baby
first try I'm getting good at that I
don't think the eyeball one will go
quite so well but either way that was a
2/4 I'm with the corridor mode which is
just absolutely panic inducing but I
hope you enjoyed it so thanks you thanks
you so much for watching if you want to
see the rest of them let me know in the
comments I'm at this point I'm still
gonna do them anyway so hope you're
enjoying so see you in the next video
Oh